to me marketing's about values this is a
very complicated world it's a very noisy
world and we're not going to get a
chance to get people to remember much
about us no company is and so we have to
be very clear on what we wanted to know
about us the way to do that is not to
talk about the speeds indeed it's not to
talk about mixing negatives it's not to
talk about why you're better than
windows question you asked was our
customers want to know who is Apple and
what is it that we stand for where do we
fit in this world what we're about isn't
making boxes for people to get their job
done although we do that well BAP is
about something more than that Apple at
the core it's core value is that
anything that people with passion can
change the world for the better
that's what we believe and we believe
that in this world people can change of
the better and that those people that
are crazy enough to think they can
change the world are the ones that
actually do core value those things
shouldn't change before that Apple
believed in at a core are the same thing
that happened and for today company
trust that it would all work out
following my curiosity and intuition
follow your heart even when it leads you
off the well-worn path you have to trust
that the dots will somehow connect in
your future the only way to do great
work is to love what you do if you
haven't found it yet keep looking and
don't settle as with all matters of the
heart you'll know when you find it don't
be trapped by living with the results of
other people's thinking don't let the
noise of others opinions drown out your
own inner voice and most important have
the courage to follow your heart and
intuition they somehow already know what
you truly want to become
everything else is secondary stay hungry
stay foolish
you just watched two amazing clips and
Steve Jobs take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]